je vois dans le journal que Johnny ALID
vous savez le chanteur a frisé la
réclusion oui oui qu'en pensez-vous non
je ne pense pas non vous ne pensez pas
quoi qu'il ait cette maladie là
intestinale à propos de concorde on
craint le véau portuaire de l'aéroport
de New
York qu'est-ce que c'est que le vé
portuaire le vé portuire c'est c'est
faire lever les gens trop tôt dans
l'aéroport de New York à cause de
l'atterrissage de Concorde qui est très
matinale Raymond bar parle de garder le
cap qu'en pensez-vous moi je vous dis
que que si c'est intéressant qu'
regardez c'est une V l'Afrique du Sud
contre la hausse du lait qu'est-ce que
vous voyez dans ta hausse du lait mettre
un antimontelit qu'est-ce que c'est
l'antimontelit antimontel c'est un petit
appareil qu'on met à la base du lait et
puis ça empêche le lait de monter au
large du Danemark et de la Norvège il
est question de supprimer les
plateformes quand pensez-vous une femme
plate c'est pas beau quand même c'est
pas joli une femme quand même quand elle
a pas de forme il y a rien il y a des
hommes qui préfèrent les plateformes ah
oui j'en connais oui